il s'appelle dominique xavier ou encore
mireille et ont tous un point commun
plusieurs heures par semaine ils sont au
total une cinquantaine de bénévoles ici
au sein des restos du coeur de plaisir
vous devez vous on a deux bons mois
voilà à la distribution des produits
frais didier il est encore en activité
mais sur son temps libre il viendrait d
une semaine sur deux je vais pévy ya
quinze ans je veux faire ça quand je
serai en retraite et après je vous suis
ni pour la face à un peu loi autres
profils jean-paul en retraite
il vient les mardis et jeudis matins en
donner des cours d'informatique
c'était pour avoir déjà une occupation
occuper d aider les gens qui auraient
besoin
au début je n'étais pas informatique je
m'occupais d'aller dans les supermarchés
récupérer la marchandise
ensuite j'ai aidé à la distribution est
depuis trois ans et à l'atelier
informatique et d la principale
motivation qui pousse tous ces bénévoles
à franchir la porte de ce centre des
restos du coeur
après une matinée d'essai ils sont
intégrés ou non à l'équipe s'il n'y a
pas de critères établis il faut
néanmoins posséder des qualités humaines
surtout est à l'écouté des autres parce
qu'effectivement ce n'est pas qu'un
problème alimentaire en général il ya
d'autres problèmes autres et là dans ces
cas là il faut il faut savoir être à
l'écouté et puis pour voir rediriger
après ce qu'on a des équipes de relais
quand même eux qui s'occupent de tout
tout ce qu'il peut y avoir d'autres
problèmes comme le logement ou
des problèmes financiers jeudi 9 heures
ok
comme la dame qui vient que je viens de
voir là et bien presque toutes toutes
les semaines pour différentes causes des
lettres administration des choses à
numériser 210 familles ont majorité
plaisir oies sont inscrits dans ce
centre selon la structure de leur foyer
elles viennent une ou deux fois par
semaine pour la distribution alimentaire
alors j'ai du jambon ça peut vous
intéresser
des nems comme ça d ouais il ya de tout
bénévole et il ya de tout dans les
accueillis aussi dont il ya des gens il
ya des gens qu'on connaît depuis quinze
ans qu'ils sont là qui il ya des gens
retirent pas alors je dirais là
le mauvais côté de ce qu'ont les gens
partent pour sais pas s'ils viennent si
c'est positif au négatif
on espère que c'est positif mais des
fois on sait pas la vie et c'est ça qui
manque un peu
c'est à dire le la presse en fait
engagement investissements chaleur
humaine
voilà ce qui ressort après cette matinée
passée avec les bénévoles des restos du
coeur de plaisir des bénévoles qui
agissent ensemble pour faire vivre la
solidarité voulu il y à 34 ans par
coluche